si vieron el vídeo anterior se dieron
cuenta de que estos problemas de
colisión pueden ser bastante complejos
el álgebra se vuelve bastante feíto y si
no vieron el vídeo y pasaron
directamente a este que por mí no hay
ningún problema en el vídeo anterior lo
que hicimos es usar la conservación del
momento pero nos quedamos con dos
incógnitas de velocidad final no
conocíamos la velocidad final de ninguno
de los dos objetos así que despejamos
esta ecuación para una de las incógnitas
y la sustituimos en la ecuación de la
energía cinética y es algo que pudimos
hacer porque la energía cinética se
conserva en las colisiones elásticas
pero como tenemos esta expresión al
cuadrado se vuelve una expresión larga y
bastante complicada además de que es
multiplicada por otras cosas y después
tenemos que combinar los términos
semejantes y al final rogamos por no
habernos equivocado en algún paso a balj
hebraico o que nos hayamos equivocado
con algún signo
aun cuando tengamos suerte y hagamos
todo perfectamente si redondeamos las
cantidades durante el proceso algebraico
nuestros resultados van a tener un poco
de error así que la pregunta obvia es
hay alguna forma más sencilla de
resolver esto estos problemas de
colisión elástica en donde tenemos dos
velocidades finales desconocidas y la
respuesta es que si justamente es lo que
vamos a ver en este vídeo y para
encontrar esta manera más sencilla de
resolver el problema
vamos a usar símbolos en lugar de
cantidades que es lo que siempre hacemos
en física para encontrar alguna solución
más sencilla siempre vamos a reemplazar
los números por símbolos o variables por
ejemplo en lugar de decir que la masa de
la pelota de golf va a ser de 0.0 45
kilogramos vamos a decir que la masa de
la pelota de golf es m g y ustedes me
pueden decir bueno y esto en que me va a
ayudar simplemente vamos a tener muchas
variables en lugar de números y vamos a
seguir teniendo este desorden y bueno
vamos a tener algo de desorden pero por
lo general cuando resolvemos problemas
simbólicamente muchas veces nos permite
encontrar patrones simetrías y
cancelaciones que de otra manera
pasarían desapercibidas si usáramos solo
números cuando tenemos expresiones
simbólicas aquí a veces suceden cosas
mágicas y es lo que vamos a encontrar
aquí vamos a tener un resultado que es
mucho más sencillo que el que
encontramos anteriormente vamos a hacer
lo vamos a resolver este problema
simbólicamente así que en lugar de tener
estas cantidades numéricas vamos a
reemplazarlas por variables en lugar de
tener esta velocidad de 40 metros por
segundo como velocidad inicial de la
pelota de tenis vamos a reemplazarla por
bt la velocidad de la pelota de tenis y
voy a poner una y para indicar que es la
inicial
esta es la velocidad inicial de la
pelota de tenis hacemos lo mismo para la
pelota de golf y ahora tenemos que su
velocidad inicial va a ser de g
en lugar de tener 50 metros por segundo
a la izquierda anteriormente cuando
escribía el 50 me refería a la magnitud
de la velocidad pero ahora cuando yo
escriba vejez me voy a referir a la
velocidad completa con todo y dirección
en otras palabras esta vejez y puede ser
negativa y de hecho si la pelota de golf
va hacia la izquierda está vejez va a
ser negativa pero vamos a tratarla como
un símbolo esta va a ser la velocidad
inicial de mi pelota de golf puede ser
un número positivo o negativo hacemos lo
mismo para las masas ya reemplazamos con
símbolo la masa de la pelota de golf y
la masa de la pelota de tenis en lugar
de ser punto 0 58 kilogramos vamos a
tener
m&t y ahora lo vamos a resolver de la
misma manera que lo hicimos en el vídeo
anterior usamos la conservación del
momento y tenemos que nuestro momento
total inicial va a ser en la masa de la
pelota de tenis por la velocidad inicial
de esta pelota de tenis más la masa de
la pelota de golf por la velocidad
inicial de esta pelota de golf y usted
me pueden decir a ver esto debería ser
un signo negativo pero no aunque yo sé
que esta pelota de golf va hacia la
izquierda estoy dejando que ésta deje y
sea la velocidad incluyendo la dirección
de mi pelota de golf por lo que
tendremos un signo negativo oculto aquí
en el caso de que vaya hacia la
izquierda es decir esta vez sería igual
a un número negativo por lo que no voy a
incluir ese signo negativo aquí ya que
de hacerlo así estaría cancelando el
número negativo que ya estaría aquí así
que aquí dejo un más y todo esto tiene
que ser igual al momento final de la
pelota de tenis que es la masa de esta
pelota de tenis por su velocidad final
btf más el momento final de la pelota de
golf que es m g por bg final y aquí es
buena idea no perder de vista cuáles son
nuestras incógnitas lo que desconocemos
son las velocidades finales pero no
y todos los valores de las velocidades
iniciales y de las masas e igual que la
vez anterior una vez que desarrolló esto
puedo despejar una sola de mis
incógnitas ya que tengo dos de ellas y
muchas veces cuando trabajamos con
ecuaciones simbólicas
buscamos simplificar la expresión lo más
que se pueda aquí no hay mucho que pueda
simplificar pero si puedo mover este
término de emt hacia la izquierda
img hacia la derecha de manera que me
queda mt por bt y menos mt x btf igual
amg por bg efe - m g por de gea y noten
que podemos tener un factor común y me
pueden decir bueno y de qué me sirve
hacerlo bueno si yo hiciera esto por
primera vez tampoco sabría yo que me
conviene hacer esto desde ahorita pero
normalmente es una buena práctica tratar
de simplificar lo más que se pueda y en
este caso en particular este es un paso
crucial así que aunque en este momento
no sea obvio porque es importante
simplificar esto desde ahorita
confíen en mí vamos a ver más adelante
porque si nos conviene del lado derecho
escribo m por vejez efe - vejez y
recuerden que no estas incógnitas son
esta vete final y esta vejez final ahora
esta expresión se ve un poquito mejor
porque tengo cosas agrupadas pero aún
así si esta colisión es elástica
entonces puedo usar la conservación de
la energía cinética lo ponemos por acá
vamos a encontrar la energía cinética
total inicial que debe ser igual a la
energía cinética total final esto va a
ser igual a un medio por la masa de la
pelota de tenis por la velocidad inicial
de esta pelota de tenis al cuadrado ya
esto le sumó la energía cinética inicial
de la pelota de golf un medio por la
masa de esta pelota de golf por su
velocidad inicial al cuadrado esto tiene
que ser igual a la energía cinética
final de todos los objetos es un medio
por la masa de la pelota de tenis por la
velocidad final de la pelota de tenis al
cuadra
más un medio la masa de la pelota de
golf por la velocidad final de la pelota
de golf al cuadrado y nuevamente hacemos
esto para tener una expresión sencilla
al final vamos a simplificar esto y
vemos que tenemos un medio en todo así
que este lo podemos quitar y lo hago
dividiendo ambos lados entre un medio o
lo que es lo mismo multiplicar ambos
lados por 2 y ya que quite estas mitades
voy a hacer lo mismo que hice de este
otro lado voy a dejar todos los términos
que tienen que ver con el mismo objeto
de un lado y los términos del otro
objeto del otro lado igualmente puede
que no sea obvio porque estoy haciendo
esto pero créanme nos va a ayudar mucho
a simplificar nos la vida tengo emt por
bt y al cuadrado y voy a restar este
término en ambos lados me queda menos m
porte btf al cuadrado y ahora tengo de
un lado mis mts y esto va a ser igual a
como voy a restar este término en ambos
lados de la ecuación me va a quedar m
por vejez efe al cuadrado menos m g v g
y al cuadrado y hacemos lo mismo que
hicimos en este otro lado vamos a
factorizar de este lado mt y de este
otro lado mg me queda mt por bt y al
cuadrado menos btf al cuadrado y del
otro lado factor y psoe mg y me queda m
g por de g
efe al cuadrado menos de g
al cuadrado y ahora la cosa se está
poniendo interesante si nos fijamos en
esta ecuación de la izquierda y vemos la
ecuación de la derecha lucen bastante
parecidas lo que es genial porque lo que
quiero hacer es incluir esta ecuación de
la derecha en la ecuación de la
izquierda y hacerlo de tal manera que se
cancelen cosas de esta otra ecuación es
decir pudimos haber despejado una de las
incógnitas como lo hicimos en el vídeo
anterior y dejar esta ecuación en
términos de una de las incógnitas y
después sustituirla aquí en la
otra ecuación y volver a tener un
desorden tremendo en donde tengo que
combinar términos pero de esta otra
manera no tendremos tanto desorden y lo
que quiero hacer ahora es dejar esta
ecuación de la izquierda más parecida a
la ecuación de la derecha habrá alguna
manera en la que yo pueda quitar estos
elementos al cuadrado y dejarlos como
estas velocidades de la derecha si la
hay si ustedes recuerdan estos términos
al cuadrado los puedo reescribir como
gmt que multiplica a la cantidad de t
- vete final x vete y más vete final ya
que cuando multiplico estos dos me va a
quedar vete y al cuadrado menos btf al
cuadrado y si no me creen hagan la
multiplicación de estos dos términos y
verán que los términos que no están
elevados al cuadrado se van a cancelar
si no me creen hagan esta multiplicación
y verán que obtendrán estos términos
así que reemplazó este término con esto
que va a ser igual y voy a hacer lo
mismo del lado derecho de esta igualdad
m&g por la cantidad de final menos eje
inicial por bg final más vejez inicial y
nuevamente si esto los multiplicamos nos
va a quedar de gf al cuadrado menos
vejez y al cuadrado nuevamente si no me
creen hagan la multiplicación para que
vean que obtenemos esto y ahora si ya
tenemos todo lo que necesitamos ahora es
cuando ocurre la magia aquí tengo m por
t por b
y vete efe y de este otro lado tengo
exactamente la misma expresión así que
lo que voy a hacer es tomar toda esta
expresión y sustituirla acá amg por
vejez efe - vejez y menos vejez y esto
lo voy a sustituir acá y me pueden decir
oye pues para qué ibas a hacer eso como
es que podemos hacerlo pues porque esta
expresión de aquí es exactamente igual a
lo que tenemos de este otro lado y yo sé
que esta expresión es igual a esta otra
así que por eso es que la puedo
sustituir son exactamente lo mismo
siempre que me encuentre con esta
expresión la voy a poder reemplazar con
esta otra de acá así que no estoy
afectando la expresión de esta igualdad
al sustituir esto aquí así que vamos a
hacerlo aquí en lugar de tener el m&t
por bt y menos btf voy a tener m g por d
efe vg que es igual a este otro término
de acá pero aún lo tengo que multiplicar
por esto otro así que esto lo voy a
poner aquí abajo por betty + btf y esto
es igual a lo que tengo de este lado
derecho e mg por dg efe - vejez y por
vejez efe más vejez y ahora ya se dieron
cuenta de la maravilla que acaba de
ocurrir puedo dividir a ambos lados
entre mg
estas se cancelan lo que es extraño
porque ahora en la ecuación final no
vamos a tener ninguna masa así que la
relación que estamos por obtener no va a
depender para nada de la masa de los
objetos lo que es bastante extraño pero
también bastante genial y aún mejor si
se fijan en este término vejez efe -
vejez y también no tenemos de este otro
lado de la igualdad así que puedo
dividir a ambos lados entre esto lo que
va a hacer que se cancelen ambos por lo
que nos va a quedar una de las
expresiones más sencillas que se puedan
imaginar vamos a hacer un poco de
espacio
y nos queda que vete inicial la
velocidad inicial de la pelota de tenis
más la velocidad final de esta pelota de
tenis btf tiene que ser igual a vejez
inicial aquí voy a intercambiar el orden
para tener primero el término inicial y
después el término final como se están
sumando no importa en qué orden las
ponga y de esta manera se verá más
parecido al lado izquierdo entonces
tengo vejez y la velocidad inicial de la
pelota de golf más la velocidad final de
esta pelota de golf vejez efe y ahora
vean qué hermosa expresión nos quedó
esto quiere decir que en una colisión
elástica si tomamos la velocidad inicial
y final de uno de los objetos ésta va a
tener que ser igual a la velocidad
inicial y final del otro objeto del
sistema y esto es sin importar cuál sea
la masa de cada uno de los objetos y yo
nunca me hubiera dado cuenta de esto a
menos que hubiéramos hecho esto de
sustituir números por símbolos para
poder encontrar aquellos términos que se
pueden cancelar pude haber resuelto
millones de problemas de colisiones
y jamás me hubiera dado cuenta de que
este era el caso y la gran razón por la
que esto es útil es porque ahora podemos
usar esta expresión sencilla en lugar de
usar la conservación de la energía
cinética ya que está conservación de la
energía cinética era la que nos daba el
dolor de cabeza por tener todos estos
términos al cuadrado y cuando ponemos
una expresión que tenemos que elevar al
cuadrado vamos a tener esta horrenda
expresión algebraica pero ahora con esta
sencilla expresión de velocidades puedo
despejar una de ellas y sustituirla en
la ecuación de la conservación del
momento en esta no tengo ningún elemento
al cuadrado y aún cuando vamos a tener
que sustituir una ecuación dentro de la
otra el proceso va a ser mucho más
sencillo y mucho menos propenso a
errores algebraicos en el próximo vídeo
veremos cómo usar este proceso para
resolver rápidamente la velocidad final
para cualquiera de los objetos
involucrados en una colisión elástica en
resumen usamos la expresión simbólica de
la conservación del momento y la
sustituimos en la
de la conservación de la energía
cinética también simbólica y terminamos
con un hermoso y sencillo resultado que
podremos usar para resolver problemas de
colisiones elásticas y así evitar usar
la conservación de la energía cinética
para cada ocasión